no single person is strong enough or
smart enough to lead by themselves and
so the opportunity isn't to beat
yourself up
but to but to understand what your
strengths are and what you bring to the
game and then find people who have
strengths that are different to yours
and if you work together and that's why
we have teams if we were good at
everything we wouldn't need the team we
just need ourselves i think it also
highlights the importance of being too
involved in your own company so that you
aren't looking for mentors
outside of your own company who are
thinking about your industry yeah or
outside your industry having um a board
of directors for me has always been
wonderful because you get people who
they were a former governor or they were
a chief medical officer of a big company
or they were in consumer marketing and
they
deeply care about the cause and happen
to care about me so it's that
safety net yeah and it seems like it's
an obligation on us as leaders to seek
out those
um mentoring relationships that are
outside of work to help create that
safety net the the they're you know
and this is i'm opening a pandora's box
here but america screwed up lean
right when when when the folks from
harvard decided to bring the toyota way
to the united states one of the biggest
mistakes they made was calling it lean
because it was never about efficiency
it was about finding better ways of
doing things which is sometimes more
efficient and leads to efficiency
but america we made it about efficiency
which means we made it about counting
which it never was
and there's never been a company that
has fully successfully implemented lean
in the united states by the way because
of that yeah because they they think
it's a numbers thing and it's not a
numbers thing
there are things within the toyota way
where we're not going to call it lean
right there are things within the toyota
way
that are brilliant and one of them is
the kaizen
where you take people who know nothing
about uh a particular part of your
business and you make them go work in
that and solve it for an a week or two
and you mix the company up and you you
let people try new things and you create
blended teams because what's happening
is somebody is bringing a point of view
that nobody on that team has so it's
actually about growth and development
exactly and so somebody from
you know
hr working on a medical thing
you know
they may say
well what about this and no one's ever
thought about that before and it's not
because they're necessarily smarter it's
because they have a different
perspective
which is you're paying me compliments
but i just have a different perspective
and this is the value of of a team
because you know and this is one of the
challenges in big companies in small
companies everybody does everything
in big companies
we become you know titanium silos of
excellence
and uh we're close to what other people
have to say because they don't
understand
as opposed to being curious
about what other people have to say
um
uh
and i loved your what you said before
it's not no because it's yes if